[Music]
Good afternoon here Steve Kaufman
again I am going to continue with this series on
the seven secrets of language learning
well first secret spend the
necessary time second second secret
and do
pleasant things third
uh be attentive to what is happening in the
language you  you are
studying fourth secret is that
words vocabulary is more
important more important than
grammar fifth number five is to
be patient patient calm
eh the sixth secret is to
obtain the necessary tool to
be successful eh For example I always
when I go in  The cle I have with me
my How to
say MP3 player
Okay there are people who have an iPod another
Player but it is very important
because when I started studying
languages ​​50 years ago we did not have the
possibility of carrying with us
a huge library of audiobooks of
texts  of very interesting things to
Listen to Every time I have like 15 or 10
minutes Okay
Eh books of course books are important
Even if someone studies in link on the
internet however eh it is very nice
to have with you eh books Like for
example in Spanish or in en  Russian or
books for example to start eh From
time to time Even if you use the link it is
also eh it helps a lot eh buy eh
those eh introductory books to the language
eh another What are there audiobooks I
really like audiobooks and an
audiobook made by  A professional is
much more pleasant because the narrator
is an artist and when you
hear well-done things, this is what
enters your head. So you don't have to
pay a lot of money, it's much less
than, for example, going to school, but
those  tools that you can also eh
lend to a municipal library
whatever but the tools a
good dictionary but above all
dictionaries
eh sun
internet because
normal dictionaries are also good But it takes
a lot of work to look up words
but with me in me I don't have it  here my
I have an iPhone and between a
bad free dictionary and a
good ionary dictionary that costs $ I am going to
buy 51 pay the $ 10 because I am going to
use it many many times so you
have to get the necessary tool
to be successful Well This is the sixth
Secret of language learning
thanks